[Music]
another week another strike this time
thousands of ambulance workers and other
999 staff in England and Wales will walk
out on Wednesday in a dispute overpay
the minister in charge of the government
response offering no guarantees on what
that will mean for emergency call-outs
we have expressed significant concern
about the impact that that will have and
we would urge ambulance strike leaders
to call it off even at this late stage
we are working incredibly hard to make
sure particularly in the most
urgent cases people are able to get that
Ambience nurses in England Wales and
Northern Ireland will also walk out on
Tuesday their second day of action with
potentially more to come next year
it's an incredibly heart-wrenching
decision because on the one hand there's
the feeling that I'm letting my patients
down
if I don't attend work
but then there's also the feeling that
I'm letting my patients down
if I don't
make my voice heard and go on strike
around 600 troops will be drafted in to
drive ambulances during the strikes with
other personnel and clinicians taking on
support roles
but there's some concern in the military
chief of the defense staff Admiral Sir
Tony radican has said while their ethos
is to serve the nation they're not spare
capacity for striking workers and needed
to focus on their primary role
from floods to covid the ministry of
defense is used to getting requests for
help from other parts of government but
the issue of whether the military are
being used readily as a policy response
rather than a last resort is a Live
question here then there's the point
that troops who can't strike are
generally getting a lower pay rise than
the workers they're being asked to stand
in for and awkward fact that's not lost
on ministers
some in Rishi sunak's party now want him
to reopen pay talks with health workers
something he so far explicitly refused
to do NHS leaders say winter pressures
and Strikes are a damaging mix I think
we're disappointed this morning but what
we're hearing
it seems for all sides is rhetoric when
what we need is imagination and a
commitment to try to
solve this dispute because it's coming
at the worst possible time in terms of
the pressures facing the NHS
but with health unions and the
government dug into their positions for
now compromise feels a long way off Rob
Powell Sky News in Westminster